I'm not much of a teacher.
Oh, now you tell me.
But I do have a great idea for science club
tomorrow.
Are you going to go back in time and keep
yourself from delivering that lecture?
I know you still don't believe me. But isn't
the foundation of science to have an open mind?
Science is about proof.
You want proof? If I remember right, this
week, a freak snowfall closed a main road
between here and Willoughby.
This week's forecast is nothing but clear
sunny skies.
Ah. We'll see.
This one's pretty nice.
That's a way better tree over there.
You're doing it again.
Huh?
Every single time I do something, you always have
to try to outdo me.
No, that's all in your head.
The academic decathlon, the 4-H
competition. Oh, I could go on.
You remember all of that? That's just proof
that you've been jealous of me ever since
back in high school.
What? You've always been jealous of me.
Please. I love my life.
Do you?
Okay, fine, I admit it. My life is far from
perfect.
But this week, I have a second chance. And I'm going to make
a difference.
Starting with getting Miss Nelson that tree.
Oh! Watch out!
I'd say the weather has changed.
Well, that's hardly proof.
Time will tell.